[Musique]
ok ok j'y crois encore quoi quoi quoi
quoi encore
je suis qui je suis naturelle
l'événement rock oublie pas c'est je
t'aime je t'aime on sait pas vous nuire
des cadets 14 des cas les katas je
t'aime je fais des cadets 14 des cas les
quatre hommes je t'aime je t'aime
[Musique]
comment ces pièces et chewbacca versé
pour rien c'est marie mais non c'est à
vous surtout avec le petit 1 marseille
avait dit chapeau c'est quoi cette tenue
n'est pas du tout la robe lamée truc
avec l'élite leurs mains sur la tête là
[Rires]
la sortie bordel vous l'attendez mardi
non mais beinheim et la droite il
pénalisait on saura se donner
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais si je vous aide et il vous est midi
[Musique]
car on a beau nous rit ça ira ouais
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
un effort de phase i attention ce salon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]